keeping it real now many people it's
amazing they become like self-proclaimed
scholars not only is this verse taken
out of context you know chapter five
verse 32 of the Quran so go ahead o God
Almighty law is saying in the Quran
killing one innocent being is as you
kill the world saving what miss Abby is
as if you say the world now so so po'pay
scholar he goes chapter 5 32 children of
Israel in other words this is the
message that was sent to the Jew the
children of Israel no no he's like no no
that's for the for the children of
Israel you guys are just doing takia
you're lying you're quoting it you know
in the wrong way and then they go ahead
and you know put a spin on it how would
you go ahead and answer this year
responding to out of context questions
most of these questions are most of
these comments that are being made and
accusations are done by cherry picking a
verse or piece of a purse without
looking at the context of the verse the
historical background of the verse or
even the translation of that verse may
not be correct and so you find that
there is a number of reasons that when
you go back to the context in which they
are making this statement or this
comment then you will find that you
understand that verse in a better light
and it is our duty because you know
people will always attack whoever they
want to attack in whatever way it is our
duty as Muslims to clarify and we have
to clarify with whatever means we have
so first and foremost I would say we
need to go back and study these out of
context passages that are constantly
coated and I know dr. Seville has a
number of them won his game piece
website that you can go back to these
verses even the translation good
translations that we have can help you
to understand better to respond better
and there are many of them many of these
things that they're taking verse or
piece of a verse and then put a spin on
it and turn them in to say this is what
Islam is violent and these are all
Muslims are on the other hand people
Muslims or people with Muslim nails who
do these crazy stuff out there and this
violent behavior they have nothing to do
with Islam and Muslims they're not
scholars by themselves they are just as
evil as the evil man in the street and
they have a Muslim name that's what the
difference is and then the whole thing
goes back to Islam and Muslim whereas we
are free from that kind of behavior from
one on that one side on the other side
that we have an explanation as well when
the Islam of folks come up with all of
these answers and you know comments and
so forth but there is a proper
interpretation that we have had over the
centuries not you know twenty sixteen or
twenty seventeen in America no that's
not how it should be done so that I of
the Quran so they find us a five I
remember 32 when we bring there and then
we coded the non slip sometimes they may
say no but this came for the Jewish
people children of Israel in other words
this is the message that was sent to the
Jews of the children of Israel you guys
are coding it out of context what we can
reply also along with what she has
mention is that yes it is also a lesson
for the Muslims there is the reason of
mass one on the rise also
that in the corral number one number two
there's not the only place where the
spirit of saving life and saying all of
humanity's mentioned it was in one of
the authentic narrations in imahara's
collection Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he said that even in a war do
not kill women and children twins
innocent means non-combatants so we can
say that yes when we look at the life of
prophet muhammad peace be upon him he
was utterly you know displeased with
when he saw the woman dead after one of
the Barons and he called his companions
and we say that he was in a war do not
kill women and children so there is we
can mention to the non-muslims there is
no carpet bombing in Islam there is no
Hiroshima Nagasaki in Islam and then
sort of eight is 61 say that if that had
me inclined towards please you also
inclined towards peace and that is Islam
so with that allegation we could show
the other passages and the sayings and
the example of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon condition unless you kill that
human being as punishment for murder or
other villainy in the land I would I
would classical Quranic interpretation
and that except verse refers to capital
punishment by the state after a trial
it's it refers specifically to the the
states right to to capital punishment if
someone actually commits murder that is
what the classical interpretation is and
so the fact that the clerics you've
spoken to haven't been able to respond
with something like that and haven't
been able to get their voices out to
young people who are reading that verse
and thinking that it means vigilantism
that they can go and haphazardly choose
who they want to kill is is certainly
not the fault it's the answer isn't
reinterpreting the reinterpretation has
already occurred by those who have taken
it and used it in their own way
joy joy
[Applause]